[Music]
the first time I saw hundreds Hall was
July 1919 nothing could have prepared me
for the spell it cast when I saw the
house again 30 years later I could
hardly comprehend the change in the
place
[Music]
why don't you tell me what's going on
you wouldn't believe me
mother this is dr. Faraday how did you
find the patient little under the
weather it's war shock they brought
Caroline home to nurse him I've heard
they're troubled very cautious about it
a long time ago who's this child here
what are you doing here this isn't dying
before I was born
there's something evil in this house
let's not shoot Betty what are you doing
here you're right four minutes
I do not all Mrs S is upstairs trying
itself today but it's more noise
[Music]
yeah
that's impossible your mind is playing
tricks
Susan is a memory it will be explained
how innocent you are
I'm worried doctor last night he said he
could smell smoke I couldn't smell
anything his delusions seemed almost
contagious
someone's playing games people are
capable with nasty impulses something in
this house that hates us you do not
belong here
oh yes
Debbie tricks tonight
weapon next there's a mystery to me
[Music]